why hello there good
people of the internet i am dave rubin
this is the reuben report direct message
for the first day of july
2021 that's right it's july 1st 2021
the summer is here couple days away from
the anniversary of the birth
of america i'm in a good mood we're
going to be doing a q a for you
as always subscribe to the youtube
channel share the videos tap the
notification bell
and see what happens before we get uh to
the q a i'm also going to be doing one
quick story
on uh lord fauci because now he's kind
of like yeah
wear a mess don't wear a mask who the
hell knows
at this point but before we get to all
of that i want to talk to you guys about
raise american you know i'm thrilled
to welcome raise american as a new
sponsor to the show a company who raises
the bar
for premier organic grass-fed beef all
over the country
for more than 15 years raise american
has been honing its processes
to provide lovers of beef the ultimate
eating experience from the feed to the
cattle to the state
raise american raises the standard of
what american organic beef ought to be
raise american cattle come from humanely
treated animals reared on
small independent american farms farms
run by family farmers and ranchers
adhering to some of the strictest animal
welfare
and sustainable farming protocols
healthy cattle make healthy beef
and no one knows that better than the
team at raise american
raise american focuses on sustainability
which is why they work closely with
these family farms to raise grass-fed
organic cattle which spend most of their
lives grazing on pastures in the fresh
open air
grazing in a way that regenerates the
soil instead of depleting it
raise american is 100 organic 100 grass
fed 100
american go to raise american.com right
now to order and learn more good for you
good for our planet good for america
on this july 4th weekend and now back to
me and as i always tell you you don't
even know
you don't even need code ruben because
they're only sponsoring us
and i will be eating plenty of beef and
barbecuing and smoking and all sorts of
stuff
this weekend and i hope you'll be
joining me so before we get to the q a
i just want to show you this quick video
of lord fauci the infallible
don't wear masks wire masks maybe wear
masks who the hell knows
this is his latest update is it safe
for us to go out and watch baseball
games if we've been vaccinated without a
mask
the answer is yes joe i mean nothing is
perfect nothing
100 there's no intervention but when you
that you could say it's absolutely 100
so there will be people
who are vaccinated who might get
infected
that's going to be a very very low
number relatively speaking
so right now that's the reason why the
cdc recommendations
have not changed joe if you are fully
vaccinated
you can go without a mask indoor and
outdoor
even though the general uh
recommendation
is you don't have to wear a mask i'm
deciding i want to wear a mask
joe there's nothing wrong with that
that's individual decision
you have to separate that from a broader
recommendation
from a public health agency like the cdc
all right so i will give fauci a little
credit here this idea of individual
decision individual choice you guys know
i believe
that and you know if you want to wear a
mask you can wear a mask if you want to
get vaccinated get vaccinated if you
want to get vaccinated and wear a mask
you can do all that so i'm kind of on
board that but notice he doesn't give
you any numbers there so he's saying
yes it's safe to go to a baseball game
outdoors if you're vaccinated he's
saying nothing is perfect you know i say
that all the time there's no
perfect system here what i don't love
about this though is even though he's
talking about
individual choice like notice he doesn't
give you any numbers like yes
if you're outdoors and you're vaccinated
and you wear a mask
you're going to get i don't know five
percent more coverage
10 15 1 because there really isn't
any numbers on that so when he's kind of
being like yeah wear the mask because
there's nothing wrong with it
well there kind of is something wrong
with it in that we'll never
take our masks off a certain set of
people
are just never going to take them off
because they've been confused
by the science or what i would say it
sometimes is
quasi science and then there's just this
idea that it's just okay
for us to just walk around forever
wearing masks not even sure
why we're doing it of course there was
the video and some still pictures from
uh july of 2020 so basically a year ago
right now where fauci was actually at a
basketball
baseball game and he had his mask now
now maybe he was eaten maybe he was
drinking but it all just leads
to this very conflicted sort of mess
related to all of this stuff
suffice to say i hope that whatever
you're doing
this weekend with your friends with your
family i hope you're barbecuing i hope
you're celebrating america i hope you're
drinking some ice cold beer
or whatever you like i hope you're in
jumping in the pool
and having fun and playing sports and
all that good stuff i hope you're doing
all that and celebrating this wonderful
free
spectacularly great place that's
struggling right now it's a struggling
we get it but we still got something
good here and i hope you're doing it uh
respectfully for yourself and the people
around you
and i think everyone is gonna be okay
that's my crate you know i'm a dreamer
and i think everybody's gonna be okay i
just i just believe
that you know how to make the right
choices for yourself i'm a crazy
right-wing nut bag what can i tell you
all right guys we got a ton of questions
at reubenreport.locals.com
we mixed it up as always so here we go
harry
says who has been your favorite
interview ever
so you know i get this question somewhat
frequently and and
one way that i answer it is that when i
sat down with thomas soul which we shot
on location in stanford a couple years
ago
it was actually the only time truly the
only time that i've
ever been somewhat nervous for an
interview i i just don't get nervous
about this stuff when i'm on stage
performing or opening for jordan
peterson i just don't get nervous i
don't know i'm supposed to be doing this
so it doesn't really make
me nervous for some reason that one i
was kind of like a little like you can
hear it if you go back to the
to that interview you can hear it at the
beginning my voice is a little softer
it's kind of cracking a little bit i was
a little nervous for that one it was
just wonderful because i was
sitting there with a legend like you
know you're there with a living legend a
guy who
probably deserves a lot more credit than
he gets and and on
you know he's 91 or 92 right now and
when he's gone one day hopefully he has
many more years
uh with us here but when he's gone one
day it's like i'll be able to say like i
sat down with that great guy and that
that incredible viral moment
you know what woke you up to marxism uh
facts
like that thing has been seen millions
and millions of times it's in
documentaries
about thomas soul people quote it back
to me all the time like that's just so
cool that i was like a little
piece of that so i would say that one
and then really i do have to say that my
my first ever in person interview with
jordan peterson
because then our lives became
intertwined and and i think so many of
you found me because of that so many of
you found jordan
because of that like and then that it
was when the whole idw
thing was really coming together and i
then ended up on tour with jordan
and it was just like there was something
so cool happening in that room
and that in that first interview that i
did in studio with him
i had first done a google hangout with
him when we didn't have a studio yet we
had just moved and it was very grainy
and choppy and i
couldn't understand everything he was
saying even because it was coming in and
out the video was the quality wasn't
great we were jacking our neighbors
internet because we didn't even have
internet yet
but when i first sat down with him for
that 12 rules
uh for life interview and we went
through each rule it was like it
felt dense and real and important to me
and then to think that i got to spend a
year in my
a year and a half of my life like
talking about that stuff with people and
seeing people turn their lives around
it's just it's awesome
that's a privilege that i have that that
the things that i've done
in these studios and the conversations
i've had i've seen the real world
examples of how they can make people's
lives better and that's pretty much as
good as it gets
storm says what has been your favorite
and or most difficult part of building
locals and the reuben report
well on the reuben report side i would
say just doing what i thought like we
had to take a lot of risks like
we left the young turks i didn't know if
that was gonna work it ended up working
we left aura tv i didn't know if that
was gonna work it ended up working
we left patreon i didn't know if that
was gonna work it ended up working you
know i've always been able when i've
seen the forks in the road and
all the times to go more independent and
do things my own way and and make sure
that i was running my own businesses and
that i was my own boss and the chances
that i fired dave rubin or slim to none
like
we're going to sit down with dave rubin
and we got to tell you know he said some
stuff and
he's in a lot of trouble now like i've
been able to make the right decisions
along the way at least on the big stuff
doesn't mean i get everything right all
the time
um but i would say the difficult parts
are that there were times where we quit
jobs where
we you know those were our salaries not
just me but my my producers my directors
and we we went out independent and kept
kept going and kept going and kept going
and going and i'm happy to say that that
i've
you know seen the the fruits of that
labor on the local side i would say
i did not intend on building a tech
company and i have to say that i
actually love it
you know i'm not doing a lot of the
day-to-day operations but i take
multiple meetings a day related to
strategy related to pr
related to fundraising related to
messaging all of those things
i would say the hardest part of it was
that for the first year and a half of
locals when we were really building
something nice and our numbers
were really looking good and we were
going into investor meetings
everybody was afraid to touch in
politics oh there's something political
about it or it's some
you're somehow a scary conservative or
something like that we don't want to put
money you know
even though people privately made your
money people people worth hundreds of
millions if not billions of dollars
privately we're like dave we love what
you're doing you're fighting the good
fight and then it was like well could
you could you throw in a little
a little cash to keep this operation
going and they were very nervous
and then suddenly something has happened
in the last six months i think the
censorship
stuff you know watching parlor get blown
up the shadow banning the de-boosting
the algorithmic tricks all the stuff
that you know it started it bubbled up
to the point that
that people were like we're gonna fund
some stuff uh and then i had
really a a two minute i mean that's all
it was a two-minute
phone call with david sachs from craft
ventures who led our last round
and he was like i'm mission aligned i
want in and i want to help you guys
and he funded us and then it opened up
the door suddenly a little bravery goes
a long way
that's what i've learned if i've learned
anything in the last couple years and by
david getting involved
then it got a whole bunch of other
big-time investors involved and now
we're well funded our burn rate is low
we're growing as you guys know we just
added
uh live stream video which i'm going to
do more of and we're thinking about
maybe doing
even a bonus show or something and this
is just the beginning like we got so
many cool things coming
so it's fun so the difficult part is uh
you know i don't have as much free time
as i used to have my voice just cracked
i think i'm going through puberty uh
jenna says what are your plans for the
long weekend
a lot of barbecuing we have a tremendous
amount of meat from raise american
uh i've got visitors here i've got my
sister and my brother-in-law my
brother-in-law who is the ceo
of locals i've got my niece and my
nephew here we've had friends here a
bunch of bunch of stragglers from my
birthday weekend
on the previous weekend so we're just
we're going to be in the pool
uh we're going to watch some movies
we're just going to be outdoors and
enjoy we're going to go on a hike with
clyde tomorrow
and and just celebrate america and be
proud of america and
you know just listening to music all day
and just enjoying ourselves i will be
shutting it down on the on the youtube
side and on the twitter side i'll be in
local saying hi to you guys and
hopefully sharing
pictures of what you guys are smoking
and barbecuing and everything else oh
and i got david got me
a little green egg you guys know about
the little green egg smoker
so we just put it all together and i'll
be smoking some meats and
all kinds of fun stuff and i hope you
guys are gonna do the same like
get out of the fight for a couple days
like you know we get out it's july 4th
celebrate this great country even if
you're watching outside of america
if you're watching this show i know you
love america like stay off the twitter
stay off the facebook for the weekend if
you want to share some food and fun
you can join us at locals uh anita says
what was your favorite part of the trump
interview and do you agree with the part
you had to block on the youtubes
oh anita you're trying to get me you're
trying to get me anita
my favorite part of the trump interview
well you know when he said to me well
first off he laughed a couple of times
and it was just nice to like like it
felt genuine to me right it didn't feel
like it was just like
like laughing just for the sake of it it
felt kind of genuine when i said that
thing to him about you know what are the
chances
i'm gonna be on youtube at the end of
this and he kind of laughed with the 10
and then later in the interview he's
like you're screwed man you're screwed
like he really did enjoy it and by the
way i heard
from his people after that he really did
enjoy it and we're gonna do something
else
uh hopefully in the not too distant
future uh my favorite part though was
when i asked
him about how in the 80s he was saying
the exact same things meaning he was on
oprah he was on donahue he was on david
letterman
saying the same exact things that he was
saying now and he said he said something
to the effect of that was a great
question like i haven't heard that
before
and like that's a cool thing to hear as
an interviewer i mean think how many
questions this guy has
been asked over the years and i thought
it was just totally relevant because i
do
watch those interviews when i'm doing
cardio you know a lot of people do
cardio they listen to trance music or
something to get their blood pumping i
watch
old ronald reagan interviews i watch old
donald trump interviews i watch
i've been watching some documentaries on
abraham lincoln and and thomas jefferson
i don't
i'm not really sweating that much it's
just kind of a i'm strolling along
with them as for the do i agree with the
part you had to block on the youtubes
um let's just say i'm happy to be here
on youtube and i think it's a wonderful
platform for all people of all walks of
life
thank you very much joe says are you
planning on putting your entire youtube
library here on locals for when they
blow up your youtube
people still have access to all your
interviews yes so we put up everything
as is right so we put up all our direct
messages all our entries and everything
but you're talking about the archives
from before we've started putting up
some of it and yes it will all be on
there eventually
and i just want to say this you know i
joke about youtube a lot look i don't
want to be kicked off youtube
i think that this is an incredible
platform that they've built and
especially for discovery for new people
to find you but i love the fact that
i've built a secure
home on locals and if all of this ended
if i was booted
from all the big tech stuff tomorrow i
still have a line of communication
uh with my mate with my main fan base
with you guys
i can chat with you text i can still
live stream you can still access my
videos and my audio and we're working on
you know i see a lot of people asking
but you don't have decentralized storage
yet we're working on it you don't have
decentralized payments yet we're working
on it like
that's the cool thing about tech like
you you build and build and build and
then
if you ever watch the show silicon
valley on hbo it's like
in the tech world you build then there's
a problem then you got to do something
else and then there's another problem
then you got to do something else next
thing you know you're
turning back you're pivoting back you've
got a different business and you're
building something else
we're we're on a nice path right now
we're gonna hopefully by
uh i don't think it'll happen until i
get back from off the grid
august but probably in the fall we'll
announce some major partnerships
some acquisitions there's there's cool
stuff happening uh and it is thanks to
you guys that allow me to
to do all this craziness uh strillin
says
when will there be a performance with
you and jordan peterson again
i'd love to it goes without saying i'd
love to you know my feelings year and a
half with that guy just
what a freaking amazing year and to just
meet so many of you guys to like
literally every day just me people i'm
off drugs
i had a better job i'm in a better
relationship i mended this
friendship i i'm talking to my parents
again like to be out there and then
you know as our tour manager said he
said this was like being with the
beatles
uh except we weren't singing on stage we
were listening to a clinical
psychologist talk about cleaning his
room
or cleaning your room like that's pretty
awesome so i would love to tour at them
again
uh you know jordan lives in canada still
and there's all sorts of crazy lockdown
situations it's even worse than in a
place
like los angeles here in california in
the states so i hope to do it again i
would definitely do it again
and one way or another by the way my
next book which will go on sale
i think we just confirmed this i don't
think i'm speaking out of school
my next book which will officially go on
pre-sale the last day of july we'll do a
big push as i about to go off the grid
it's the la i'm going to announce the
book we're going to show you the cover
you'll be able to purchase it we're
going to do a signed number situation
just for that first day um that will be
will officially be out in april of 2022
publishing world is kind of slow but
they get there uh and then yes i am
going to tour i'm going to tour
throughout the country
you know i missed my entire book tour
last time which sucked you know we had
we had
like 30 theaters basically sold out
across the country
ready to go and i want to get to europe
and everything else anya says
this will be my first fourth of july as
an american citizen
welcome anya what should i bring to a
potluck that i'm invited to
this is gonna be your first fourth of
july well first off that's just awesome
that's just awesome we are a country of
immigrants we love people that love
america and i have no doubt that you do
and i'm i'm thrilled to hear that you're
now an american citizen i'm sure it was
not an easy
trek and an adventure to get here and i
know it's legally a mess i got a friend
going through it right now
it can take some time so congratulations
that's really wonderful what should you
bring to the potluck
um well you can oh you know americans we
love beef we love meat
right oh there goes that that's the uh
that's the promo for uh today's show
um you know uh i've been big on tequila
lately i know it's thought of as more
mexican it originally comes from mexico
but
check out a closet zul bottle fancy
bottle it's not cheap about 150 bucks
but you're gonna give people a nice
sipping tequila everybody's gonna be
happy
and enjoy fourth of july all right there
you go and the beauty of america is
that's not cultural appropriation that's
cultural appreciation
because we love mexican things here we
love canadian things here we love
italian things here
that's what america is all about we are
a melting pot people
mark says is there any reason that
locals.com can't evolve to become the
free speech alternative to twitter and
facebook
it would not take many additions for
locals to capture the most important
functionality of those two monsters so
you know we've
we've discussed it and as i just said
we're going to announce a couple things
in the
fall related to all that my feeling
first was let's
secure homes for creators right like
let's make sure
i got a place for my video my audio chat
all as i said all those things i can get
the
push notifications out to you guys live
video let's do that for
secure individual people and then we can
sort of build out the bigger things so
we do have bundle
packaging coming we have an
unmanipulated algorithmic feed
so it's it's completely chronological
and then you can filter it if you want
by we have a couple options that let you
filter it but we don't filter it for you
in other words
um so we could replicate a twitter type
situation
and by the way it would all be a lot
more pleasant because it costs a couple
bucks to get in like that's it
like you know like most things in life
you got to pay for you got
you want to get a new shirt you got to
pay a couple bucks but for some reason
we think that these things that we keep
in our pockets all the time that these
all these apps and everything should be
free and it's because yeah we're the
product
um i don't know that i want to replicate
facebook per se
but we're going to add as much of the
functionality of those things as
possible and what's cool is we're
building it all and we own it all we've
got an incredible team of programmers
and uh and we're doing it and we're
doing it without without going the
traditional routes
we really are um and and hopefully over
the next
however many months i can show you a
little more of the under the hood stuff
and how we run the business and
everything because it's a very cool part
of
just this thing that you guys are now in
on with me uh carol says one of the many
reasons i listen to you is that in my
opinion you are the you are honest and
genuine
you help us stay grounded i would like
to know if you are afraid of losing
those qualities
as you're growing your business and if
you have a plan in place to avoid this
common
pitfall thanks for what you do um you
know i don't have a
plan for it but i'm aware of it right
like
i've seen it i've seen it happen to uh
friends and colleagues and everything
else where
you sort of get a certain amount of
notoriety a certain amount of public
success a certain amount of financial
success
and it does kind of change you i think
that i'm pretty much
the same person that i always was
actually when we had my birthday party
last week like i had my
best buddy john who i've been friends
with for 41 years met when we were four
years old
and and i had new friends that you guys
know from the show and it's like
those people all like the same guy right
like this this is me
i mean the thing is when you turn on a
camera i do i turn it on like
three percent that's really it like i
act the same way with my guys that are
in this room right now and
i act the same way with david and my
family and everything else um
you do always have to be aware of that
you know you have to be aware of not
falling into audience capture and only
delivering you guys what i think you
want i just have to basically stay true
to myself and i think if i
i think if i do that then that's pretty
much the best
that you can do all right one more
question for you and then i want you
people to close your computers
and take off tomorrow friday if you can
and enjoy the freaking weekend people
dixie says what is your pick for a movie
that celebrates our independence day
we are wanting to do a movie weekend and
show some great ones
well the first thing that pops into mind
you say independence day it's like you
can watch independence day yes it's
about
uh proclaiming our independence from
aliens but in some ways that's exactly
what we're dealing with right now i mean
what are the aliens
in independence they want they wanted
complete submission
of the human race and that's pretty much
what the woksters want too right they
want to annihilate all of us they don't
want to negotiate
there's no half measures with them
remember that part of the movie when
when the president when he realizes when
the alien talks to him through telepathy
or whatever
and he's like whoa they want complete
extermination like they're not here to
oh let's share the planet just like
these guys they're not really here to
share the country they kind of want
us to bow forever so alien alien
invasion very close to woke invasion so
you watch independence day
i would say also great american movie
that will make you proud to be an
american
when we knew what america was i believe
it was 1985
rocky iv right rocky balboa fighting
ivan drago on christmas day
in moscow raising the american flag at
the end
just a beautiful story of america we
knew who the good guys were we knew who
the bad guys were
just pretty much perfection and i'll
give you one other you know what if
you've got young kids
we've got my niece and nephew staying
here and just last night we did a movie
night we watched
adam's family values you see the adams
family movies
it's the second one it's pretty funny
that christina ricci she's good actress
i don't know what happened to that girl
but
it's a funny movie even for an adult
pretty it's pretty
pretty pretty good guys part three of my
interview with christian angermeier all
about life extension and psychedelics
and how to conquer depression and all
sorts of interesting stuff that is up on
youtube right now full episode of course
up at reubenreport.locals.com uh we have
no round table tomorrow because i don't
want you sitting at your computer
and i want you to hopefully enjoy an
extended weekend if at all possible
and as i said if you want to share food
pictures
booze pictures american flag pictures
and videos and whatever music you're
listening to
and good times you're having with your
family and friends join us at
reubenreport.locals.com
have a great fourth of july everybody
and uh
god bless america god bless you guys
i'll see you on monday